[Music]
hey you guys me again
time for another book review book we're
talking about today is one that was
recommended to me by a
listener and i'm really glad that they
recommended this one because this one
was actually a really fun
read this one is called the hollow
places
by t kingfisher now t kingfisher
is actually a pseudonym of an
author and artist named ursula vernon
now i hadn't read any of her other stuff
apparently she's kind of better known
for doing children's books i think she
did a series called the hamster princess
and she did one called i think dragon
breath so she did like a bunch of those
she also does i believe is a web comic
called digger
and she does like a lot of digital art
and stuff like that but under the name t
kingfisher she actually writes horror
fantasy stuff like that for adults
and this is actually the first one of
hers that i ended up reading this came
out
back in october of 2020 so it's fairly
recent
a lot of people too have recommended
another one that she wrote i believe
a year or two before this one which is
called the twisted ones and actually i
enjoyed this one so much that i will
probably go back and read that one
and probably review it at some point
although it might be a while before i
get to it but so
the setup of this one it's really
interesting because
i've i saw like a lot of other uh
channels reviewing this and i read a lot
of reviews of it on goodreads
seems to be getting really positive
feedback and everything although i feel
like
98 of the reviews didn't
acknowledge or didn't know that this is
actually
based loosely on the algenon blackwood
classic horror story the willows
which actually if you have never read it
h.p lovecraft called it one of the
most frightening stories in the english
language i actually did a reading of it
on my
witching hour show a while back so
basically
this story takes the premise of the
willows which is kind of about
these willows being almost like
elder god type of thing is it's a very
cosmic horror type of concept
and kind of transplants it to the modern
day so it's not like this idea of these
willows
being sort of like elder gods or
something that
that doesn't come out of nowhere that
actually comes from the algernon
blackwood story
so i don't know if anybody and actually
at the end of the book she does
acknowledge that's where she got the
idea from because she's
talking about how she got the idea from
the book and how she wanted to kind of
expand on that mythology a little bit
or as i said bring that concept of the
of that story up into the modern era so
what you have
is you have this young woman i believe
she's in her 30s and her name is kara
um she has just gotten a divorce from
her husband mark
and she's kind of um you know as you
probably would be at a crossroads in her
life
and she doesn't have a lot of money so
she decides she's going to move back to
her hometown
of hog chapel north carolina
now she's initially going to stay with
her mother uh this is a proposition that
isn't really all that enticing for her
because
her and her mother don't really get
along however something that ends up
happening is that her uncle earl who is
a delightful human being
he uh says that she can have a place to
stay
and a place to work in his museum
which is downtown in this little bitty
little town
now this museum has the wonderful
wonderful name
of the glory to god museum of
natural wonders curiosities and
taxidermy
so basically uncle earl is kind of one
of those
lovable old coots who is just
who kind of just believes everything he
must believe in aliens and bigfoot and
mothman
and so he has this really quirky museum
that just has all this really cool [ __ ]
in it like all these
weird taxidermied animals all this kind
of stuff like he has a fiji mermaid he
has all this kind of crazy i mean i love
that kind of stuff so i love that
uh this story was set in that
environment because it was just like a
really fun
environment for this story to be set in
so cara has grown up in this museum
and she always had a great deal of
affection for it she always had a great
deal of affection for
for uncle earl so he basically gives her
a room in the back of the museum
and says you can live here rent free as
long as you help me out with the museum
you know help me do
uh an inventory because he's never done
one everything's just kind of
thrown around whatever and she uh very
happily takes him up on this
offer now as it turns out shortly after
she moves in
uncle earl ends up having to get surgery
i believe it's like some knee surgery or
something like that so he's kind of
he's in it a little bit at the beginning
but then he's kind of out of commission
for most of it and she's
sort of running the museum all by
herself as i said it's a very small town
so you just kind of get these little
tourists
uh popping in there every now and then
like to buy some t-shirts and mugs and
going hey
look at all this crazy [ __ ] in here so
she's you know she's she's having a fun
time
uh you know working in the museum and
getting back in touch with all the cool
[ __ ] she loved in her
childhood now she also has a friend
uh this dude named simon who is a
barista
at the coffee shop next door because i
think uncle earl like owns the whole
building
so he rents out to several other uh
little shops and [ __ ] like that like in
this little bitty downtown area
now simon is kind of and i don't mean
this to sound
uh dismissive because he actually
probably really is the best character um
he's kind of like your stereotypical
like sassy gay
uh sidekick um he also has like kind of
a goth
kind of thing going on he's like always
wearing fishnets and a top hat and he's
got like nick cave posters in his
apartment which is over the coffee shop
and so
he but he's just like a real funny he's
kind of like the comic relief character
so i think one of the best things about
this book the thing that one of the
things that i enjoyed the most
was that there's a really lot of humor
in it and a lot of humor stems from
kara and simon's interactions as this
crazy [ __ ] starts to happen which i'll
get into
in a minute and just the just the them
trying to deal with
this really mind-blowing uh you know the
disbelief
that they feel of all this crazy stuff
that's going on
and it's almost kind of like they're
using humor as a defense mechanism
because they just can't believe how
nuts all this [ __ ] that it is that's
happening so what ends up happening
is that one day kara is upstairs and she
notices what she thinks at first
is that some tourist has knocked their
elbow into the drywall or something like
that and has
knocked a hole in the wall of the museum
so obviously she's a little bit annoyed
about this
she gets simon to help her out in uh you
know kind of closing up the hole or
whatever but then
as they're looking into the hole they
notice something very interesting
because
rather than being the normal [ __ ] that
you would see behind
the wall of the museum they see this
really big
long concrete hallway
which seems like it shouldn't really be
there considering how the
you know how the building is configured
they're like that really shouldn't be
there so
how curious so they decide that they're
going to check it out and see what the
hell is going on back there
it's like some kind of i mean i think
initially she thinks oh it's extra room
for the museum and maybe
you know uncle earl didn't even know
this was back here and we need more
space anyway
so maybe we can knock this wall out if
there's all this room back here that's
not being utilized
so they um eventually end up kind of
smacking down this hole in the wall
and there's this like really weird like
concrete hall back there
now one of the first weird things that
they notice is that
on the outside of the wall i'm not sure
if i'm going to be able to
describe this adequately but like on the
outside of the wall you have like the
drywall that they
you know were kind of taking off like to
make the hole bigger
but then on the other side of it was
concrete so it's all kind of like
concrete
but drywall and she's like well wait a
minute that
that can't happen it's kind of like so
it's actually this really strange
like transmogrification of materials i
guess you would call it
so that's kind of the first inkling that
they have
that something is not right with this
space behind this hole in the wall so
basically her and simon crawl through
there and they're starting to go
up and down and uh you know trying to
figure out what's going on back here
and as they go farther and farther down
the hall they're just like okay well
this can't happen because
from the outside geography of this
building we should be outside or like
over the street you know what i mean
because it's just it's taking up too
much room
so at this point you know that this is
like some narnia [ __ ] going on okay this
is like not
this is some interdimensional kind of
what's this that's going on behind
this wall so basically they find this
door
and they finally get this door open and
they find
basically a dead body in there it's a
skeleton and they can't figure out how
long it's been there it looks like it's
been there a very long time they can't
figure out
what this dude was doing here where he
came from or anything like that so the
mystery is deeper and deeper
now as i said from this point forward as
i say in almost all my reviews
probably there'll be some spoilers so if
you don't really want to know anything
more about the story then obviously turn
off now go read the book and then come
back because i probably
am going to be spoiling some aspects of
it that you may may not want
spoiled for you so this is your final
warning
uh please go read it and then come back
if you want to continue the discussion
thank you so after they find this body
they kind of start freaking out and then
they're like there's this big debate
over it's like well
should we call the cops and then they're
like well maybe we shouldn't because the
body's been there a really long time and
at this point they've
pretty much figured out that this is
some kind of weird extra dimensional
rift or something because there are all
these kind of impossible things
about the architecture of this place as
you know compared to
the outside of the building it's like
you know it's it's impossible and it
shouldn't be there
so they're basically like well we can't
have cops swarming in here um you know
uncle earl is still having surgery it's
like what if they come in here and
tear everything up what if they close it
he'll be heartbroken
it you know this places his life and
everything like that so they decide
they're not going to call the cops but
they are curious enough that they're
going to keep
exploring this very strange uh
thing that's happening so as i said at
one end of the hall
there's a room that has a dead body in
it at the other end of the hall there's
this other like big metal door
that they can't get open at first but
they actually kind of get all all their
gear together
and they do end up opening the door and
much to their astonishment they find
that behind this door
what they're in the concrete thing is
essentially
they they end up calling it like a
bunker it looks like somebody built it
as some kind of safety mechanism or you
know what i mean something like that
so but they get this door open and they
end up like they're
outside and it's just if you've read the
algernon blackwood
story the willows it's kind of like what
was described in that
story but a little bit more of kind of a
fantasy type of
situation where it looks as though
each of these there are all these little
there's like a body of water like some
kind of lake or swamp or something like
that
and then there are all these little like
humps of land
that are coming out out of the water and
it appears that in each of these humps
of land
there is a similar like a bunker
something that's like
built into you know each one of these
little hills and there are willows
everywhere
uh it's very foggy and there are some
it seems like they hear some birds and
stuff like that every now and then but
there's not really
they don't see a lot of animals or
anyone else
and so they're sitting there thinking
well this is definitely
some kind of they figure out it's some
kind of interdimensional like way
station or something like that
and as their exploring goes on
they determine that
some other people have been through
there and that these
other people are from a very similar
world to ours but just
a little bit different you know what i
mean so it's like they'll have
like they find this one bunker this
other one that they go to
and a lot of the stuff there seems like
human stuff like from our world
you know they find like a porn magazine
and they find a bible and stuff like
that but there's just
little things in it that are different
so you can tell it's from like a
slightly
different universe so this is basically
like a way station where all of these
alternate universes sort of spill into
now at first as you would they find this
pretty fascinating
but then the more they explore the
creepier and creepier
the [ __ ] gets um i don't want to spoil
too much of the imagery because there is
i won't say this is a super scary book
but it does have
a lot of very unsettling
imagery in it you know i will say you
know they they find a school bus
uh that has some pretty creepy [ __ ] in
there they find this one guy
who's down in one of the bunkers kind of
in the water
and he's kind of stroking something
that's under the water and at first they
think that it's his hair like he has
this really long hair
but it turns out that that's not what it
is uh so there's a lot of
really really creepy imagery like that
even though like i said there's
i wouldn't really call this a really
really scary book just because
just because so much of it is funny and
humorous
because these two people like kara and
simon
are just they can't believe this [ __ ]
you know what i mean it's it's so
they're they're so overwhelmed with how
strange this [ __ ] is
that they're just constantly quipping
back and forth like trying to make
themselves
be less afraid so they're always trying
to be funny so
um you know how i'm not sure how you
feel about that maybe you think that
makes it scary or maybe you think it
makes it less scary
i'm not really sure i did like a lot of
the humor in it but i can see how some
people might be like oh well the humor
kind of undercuts the horse it makes it
less scary because
they just can't believe what's going on
so they just keep making jokes about it
but i don't think it bothered me that
much because
i feel like that's kind of what you
would do in that situation
particularly if you're that kind of
personality type i mean
if you actually went through a hole in
the wall in this little rinky dink
crazy museum somewhere in north carolina
and suddenly there's this massive
interdimensional kind of way station
somewhere that's
impossible and that can't exist and you
also have to
contend with the fact that you know all
of these other alternate universes exist
and you didn't know that they existed
before
then probably that's what you would do
because it's just make jokes because
otherwise you just kind of go insane
so so problem rises when they kind of
come across all this really scary [ __ ]
and then they kind of get
lost in there because they can't really
because everything kind of looks the
same
and even though they mark to where their
particular bunker was
when they emerge back into the thing you
know fog is lifted you know the
um you know sometimes it's implied that
maybe the trees move around by
themselves just kind of like in the
algernon blackwood story
where there was a constant implication
that the trees were
alive and were moving around or like
were coming closer
but you couldn't actually catch them
moving so there's that
implication as well so even though they
marked the spot where their bunker was
the environment had you know is kind of
constantly changing
so they aren't really sure so it takes
them like a day or two
before they can find their way back to
the
their bunker and find their way back to
the shop now interestingly about halfway
through the book they actually do find
their way back to
the store and are trying to
figure out what they're going to do
about it because basically like well
that was a horrifying experience like
all the [ __ ] that happened to them over
there
um let's not do that again which is
again what what you would do
so they kind of tried to pass just sort
of patch up the hole and it's like okay
well
eventually we'll bring in some concrete
and we'll just fill this all in because
we don't want somebody wandering in
there by mistake or
you know whatever something bad
happening to uncle earl when he comes
back from his surgery
so they're like but for now we'll just
put up some sheet metal or something
just to keep people from looking at or
keep people from wandering in there
and i was at this point i was kind of
like oh interesting i didn't think
i thought the rest of the book was just
gonna be them like exploring and finding
more
scary [ __ ] so i was really interested
that i was like oh what's gonna happen
now now that they got back and they
decided like a smart person would hey
we're not going back in there because
yeah it's really really bad and as i
said just in the algernon blackwood
story
you kind of see the trees and
things it's kind of hard to explain like
i said because it's cosmic horror
but there's things like in between the
trees that are kind of
you can kind of just see like the shapes
of them and there's also kind of a thing
where
particularly simon who seems to have a
little bit of i guess what you would
call like a psychic ability they don't
go super into it but
he makes a joke that he uh
consumed his twin in the womb and that
so
his running gag is that one of his
eyeballs
is from his twin sister and that's what
gives him his
psychic ability or because his actual
vision
is really really bad but he seems to
have like this imperfect
second sight and he attributes it to
having swallowed his twin in the womb
and that's just like her eyeball that's
still in his head
so that's kind of how he i mean he you
know he he says it like in a funny way
but that's kind of how
he explains it so sometimes he can
see things that cara can't see in the
sense that
even though something isn't there he can
sense that it's there like kind of with
this psychic power and stuff like i said
it's not overdone
it's not cheesy or anything like that
it's just like a little extra
ability that he has that she doesn't
have so
it turns out that after they get back to
the store and kind of get it all covered
up and they think okay well you know
that's
all we're gonna do about that until we
can get the hole filled up with concrete
but then it turns out
that the place is not
finished with them and it
almost seems like it's trying to
pull them back into it like by making
them sleepwalk
um because kara keeps waking up in the
middle of the night and like her fingers
are all messed up
and a couple of times she has woken up
and is like trying to claw
the um you know the sheet metal off and
she's so she's trying to get back in
there so it's almost kind of like
because they've been to this place it's
trying to kind of
reclaim them so that's kind of how
they end up having to go back there
because of particular things that happen
around that type of thing
now i will say too that there is
a reason why this hole appeared
and it's interesting because it seems
very obvious to the reader
pretty much as soon as the thing like
arrives in the store you know that it
has some particular significance just
because
it's described and so you know that it
has significance
and that's kind of one thing it's that
it seems like it took cara a long time
to figure out that this object was kind
of the cause of
this whole opening up because apparently
there are these
holes kind of going into this weird
willow world
everywhere and they don't necessarily
have to be behind a wall they could just
be because like i said in the world they
found a school bus
so you're just assuming that somebody
drove a school bus into the wrong area
one day and
they were just in the middle of uh you
know this willow world all of a sudden
with all of these kind of elder god type
creatures
looking for them um and that's another
thing too
is these creatures even though they're
not i don't even know if i'd call them
creatures because like i said it's
cosmic horror
but there are these things that they'll
consume you or if they're not hungry
then they'll just play with you and
they'll do really [ __ ] up [ __ ] like
just
unraveling your skin like while you're
alive and [ __ ] so this does have some
kind of horrific imagery in it even
though as i said a lot of it is
humorous but it does kind of have these
really disturbing
images in it as well but uh but yeah so
that's kind of the whole thing about
these monsters or whatever they are
they'll either just eat you which in a
lot of ways is kind of
better um because if they don't want to
eat you if they don't happen to be
hungry at that time
then they'll just [ __ ] with you and
they'll and you'll still be alive but
they will
change you in various horrible
ways which you do see glimpses of over
the course
of the story now as i said i don't want
to spoil the ending too much
um i liked the way it ended
because it it didn't go exactly the way
i expected
but it was still a satisfying enough
ending it's i mean it's a it's a weird
premise
for sure uh it's almost kind of like
i don't want to say it's more sci-fi or
fantasy than horror but it definitely
has some sci-fi
fantasy elements to it and it's very
alternate universe
um you know and as i said if you've read
the algenon blackwood story you can kind
of
get the gist of where it's coming from
it's like that but funnier
and there's some kind of crazy like
absurd kind of imagery too at the end
but also
sort of i don't know it's kind of like
comforting because it's almost like the
objects
in the wonder museum
where she works are almost kind of like
imbued with
all the affection that she and uncle
earl have given them over the
over the years so it's almost kind of
like they end up helping her in the end
um which sounds weird because you're
talking about a bunch of taxidermied
animals but
you'll see what i'm getting at also have
to say
i really like the character and he is
in this enough to be considered a
character of beau
the badass cat i really like i feel like
there's a lot of stories where
there's like a hero dog you don't see as
many stories with a hero cat
i'm always kind of like i don't know i
mean even kind of like
in a lot of stories and horror movies
and stuff like that like there'll be a
cat in it and they're just kind of
incidental to the story or they're just
there for everybody to go oh kitty and
then something horrible happens to them
you know what i mean
so i like that in this story
beau the cat was actually quite a large
character and actually contributed a lot
to the climax and helped kara you know
at the end when everything was starting
to go bat-shit crazy
so i really really like that and i like
that
she thought about the cat a lot because
it's not a kind of thing where it's like
oh you know all this bad shit's
happening in the store i got to get the
[ __ ] out of here
she was kind of like i gotta get bo and
get out of here because i'm like that's
what most real people that had a cat
would do they'd be like
they're not just gonna run out without
the kitty i mean you know what i mean
you guys know me i'm a cat person so i
so i like that that
the the cat was that much of a character
and also that the cat contributed so
much
to the climax and contributed to all the
stuff that was going on like helped
fight some of the monsters and
stuff like that so i thought that was
really really awesome and i was afraid
that something bad would happen to the
cat but it didn't so
you know so that's good this is good
because a couple of the last
uh books i did like the last two books i
did
i think had something terrible happen to
dogs so i was kind of afraid that this
was going in the same direction i'm not
saying that you shouldn't put that in
your stories i'm just saying that
i did i get real upset like when when
there's animal cruelty
so when the cat first appeared i was
kind of like oh man i hope nothing bad
happens this kitty because he sounds
really awesome
so i really like that the cat was
actually kind of a hero in his own
regard and a character in his own regard
so i thought that was pretty cool
now if i had any criticism about this
but i don't really have a lot of
criticism about this book like i said
it's not
real real scary some people found it
scary which you know that's
up to them i guess um i didn't find it
scary but i did find it really really
entertaining
and i thought that a lot of the um
imagery was really
creepy and really well described as i
said i really really like that story
the willows so i really thought it was
intriguing an intriguing premise to take
that idea take that story and expand
upon it and
bring it into the modern era which i
thought was a really good idea i do kind
of wish
one thing that i do wish is that i wish
that they had gone
and explored some of the other
alternate universe i mean realistically
if this really happened to you
i mean i hope it doesn't but if this
really did happen to you if you found
this [ __ ] alternate universe behind a
wall or something and there was all
these bunkers
that you figured out went to alternate
universes some of which might be super
different to ours some of them
um seemed real similar but just a little
bit different
like little details and things probably
it would be a dumb idea to go exploring
other alternate universes because you
wouldn't
know if you'd be able to get back or you
know things like that
but i do kind of wish that since that
premise was introduced
it would have been cool if we'd been
able to see a little bit more of some of
the other
alternate universes even though you do
get implications about them because as i
said they do find
evidence of some kind of military
exploration unit that was in one of the
other bunkers
and they kind of go through all their
stuff so
they know you know that these people are
from a very similar
universe to ours so there is kind of
that implication
but i do kind of wish there had been a
but the thing about it though is that it
seems like
this book could easily lead to
a whole series really and i mean i'm not
saying that
that it's that it seems unfinished or
anything like that i'm just saying i
mean it stands alone very well also
um you know just it's very good
standalone story but if you wanted to
expand it out into a whole series of
books then you could totally do that and
there would be a really lot
of stuff still left to explore although
i would
i would say that since i liked the
characters of kara and simon and bo the
cat
uh so much and uncle earl actually uncle
earl was also a kick-ass character and
he
it'd be cool if you could see more of
him too because he was kind of only in
the beginning and the end because he was
having surgery all through the middle
so he wasn't even in the store when all
this crazy [ __ ] was going on but
you know it'd be actually kind of cool
to see them
exploring more of this kind of stuff
even though i think at this point you
probably can't because you know holes
close up and all this other stuff but um
so as i said it's still a standalone
story but it would be cool to see these
same characters return and you know kind
of expand out on the universe and maybe
like explore some of these different
bunkers and
who the hell lives in there and what the
hell's going on over there and
it would just be really cool but you
know as i said this is a really really
fun
entertaining book t kingfisher has
written a whole bunch of stuff
as i said for adults i've as i said i've
seen
one called the twisted ones which a lot
of people have recommended
so i'll probably get around to reading
that one as well at some point
and as i said she's kind of known as a
children's book author and illustrator
too
and i haven't seen any of her work in
that regard but i'll definitely be
looking out for some more stuff because
this was just a real fun read um you
know just
just fun funny entertaining with some
creepy stuff in it
and um you know referencing a really
good 1911 i believe this
the original algernon blackwood story
was from 1911 if i'm remembering
correctly
you know referencing a story from back
then that i really really like so i
think that was a really great
concept to take that story and modernize
it
and kind of expand out the lore and
stuff like that so that'll do it for
this episode of tomes of terror and i
will see you on the next one
bye